this is a production of cornell
university
good afternoon everybody thanks for
coming today to
help celebrate and learn more about the
caja program the cornell africa um
horticulture assistantship
and this is a really
tremendous program that we have here in
the section of horticulture and the
school of integrative plant sciences
it's now
what press about
almost 20 years in the in the making
just shy of 20 years
and it's um a program that has is really
meant to build
sustained uh deep relationships between
horticulture at cornell and horticulture
in africa and i think you're going to
hear today
some wonderful examples of how that's
happening
and then we also
have a wonderful um new chapter to the
caja story that we'll learn about today
um it is expanding and growing a new a
new opportunity so
we'll we'll talk about that more today i
wanted to draw your attention to this
article that came out in the cornell
chronicle
last week about the program and if you
didn't get a chance to read it um i
encourage you
to read it
i think you'll be inspired to after
hearing from
all the people featured in this story
today so we're going to have
the opportunity to hear from four people
today
we're going to start by um hearing from
professor chris wien who was is an
emeritus professor from horticulture
here a long time before i retired a few
years ago and it's really chris's vision
that has built the kaha program
um that then we will hear from
kalangabanda who is our kaha student who
is finishing
her phd i'm here at cornell
we will then hear from phil griffiths
who is
uh was a mentor to the first papa
scholar and so he now can look back on
the last decade or so and and reflect on
how the program has
um built that um sustained bridge
between cornell
and africa and then we'll hear from
julian who is our incoming haha student
she just joined us this fall from uganda
and so she's got an exciting
road ahead so with that i'm going to
turn it over and then after we'll have
about 15 minutes for discussion so
please um
uh do do stay for
a discussion with all four speakers
afterwards okay first over to you good
afternoon everyone
it's a pleasure to be here to be back at
cornell
uh and it's nice to be able to
acquaint you with or review with you a
program which we got started initially
anonymously
in about 2006 or so
and
it's been going on and uh i'm very happy
that that's the case
if this is
well
yes um
so
i guess i've been in love with cornell
for quite a long time
i came here as a graduate student in
1964
and
in the old veg cross department
and then
[Music]
went through a master's degree working
mostly on
domestic problems
and i come from canada
where tropics are
not existent
and uh
but i was always interested in tropics
and cornell just has this wonderful
set of opportunities for someone's
interest in topics that doesn't
necessarily come from there
and so
in 1968
the international ag program
had a trip during
the winter break
to puerto rico
this was the first
time that this chorus was doing this 11
days going around
in january we're here it's
distinctly inhospitable as you know
to go to the tropics
where everything's green and growing and
just wonderful
and we learned about agriculture in all
parts of puerto rico
and
i enjoyed that tremendously
and
i had already
started thinking of
maybe doing a phd thesis
that combined some work in the tropics
and at that point the
cornell
university of the philippines program
had gotten started
and was inviting graduate students to do
their thesis research
in philippines even ones coming from
canada
who would who would think such a thing
and so
my wife and i
uh
let me see if
not very well anyway sir my late wife uh
betty
and i went to the philippines
in 1968
stayed at the university of philippines
i did part of my phd thesis research
there helped in some teaching
uh traveled all over the philippine
islands just enjoyed it tremendously
and
so that was
a
unique experience as far as i was
concerned
uh
and
a very enjoyable one
then uh in
1972 so i came back finished my phd
did a year's postdoc again in wedge
crops
and uh
in 1972
the vice
director of
the international institute for tropical
agriculture in nigeria in ibadan
uh came around looking for someone to do
grain legume physiology to become member
of their their staff they said well i
did beans in the philippines with that
count
and he said sure yeah so come on
[Laughter]
so okay so we spent seven years
uh in
nigeria and traveled all over the
continent
uh
had projects in
tanzania and niger
and also visited a bunch of other
countries just loved it
tremendously at the end of that seven
years
uh my wife informed me i'm going home
you make your mind up and i said well
if i stay longer in iita
i would be a tropical horticulturist and
maybe i would just as soon dabble in it
rather than have it as a full-time job
and so
we came back
uh cornell was looking for somebody to
do veg crops
work uh so i came back into the old
department
and uh
became
uh
just
the faculty member here
and again
there were possibilities of still being
engaged
in
uh
in tropical agriculture and i
was lucky enough to uh
dabble in in some of that
including
the cornell international
institute for food agriculture and
development cfad
china
established a program in zimbabwe at the
university of zimbabwe it was somewhat
similar
to the work that
the upco program was doing
and uh smaller scale and
not as long term
but
nevertheless uh interesting
and so i participated in that
led some of the effort
but you can see from the summary
19 faculty members involved
students from the of zimbabwe came to
cornell got cornell degrees
and then two students did part of their
thesis work
the students from here did their thesis
work there
so it was a similar program
but it continued
our involvement in
africa and uh to me was
was fascinating
so
the university of philippine program i
just want to go back to that briefly
is uh
one that
essentially started the international ag
program at cornell it was in the 1950s
shortly after the second world war the
universe philippines had been occupied
by japan
the
campus was used
by the japanese for internment of
prison earth and the campus was in
pretty sad shape
and
with some funding from usaid as well as
later on from
rockefeller and ford foundations that
program was really quite a long-term
program involving
many cornell professors who spent one to
two years in the philippines teaching
doing research and so on and then had
these graduate students mostly from
cornell us
uh
and to one or two
strangers like the canadian i am uh
and uh
so it it had quite a profound influence
not only on university philippines but
also on
cornell's international involvement
and
so so that as a model
uh for this kaha program
was
something that you know i could easily
come back to
and essentially what we're trying to do
with kaha
is to train african graduate students in
horticulture so taking students
from african countries bringing them
here
letting them do their thesis
partly their thesis but their coursework
and so on here
but then sending them back to their home
country or to some international
institution in africa where they would
do the bulk of their research then come
back and get a cornell degree then the
stipulation
is okay
now that you've done that you
need to
devote your time and effort uh to to
africa
the second phase which we're just
starting now
is one which involves which we hope will
involve
african americans
who again have an interest in
horticulture who have an interest in
africa and who would be willing to take
part
in a program
such as this
so they would have a thesis advisor here
but then link up with an institution in
whatever country it might be in in
[Music]
sub-saharan africa
but then
finish up here and hopefully
we can twist their arm to
then go back and devote
at least part of their career to african
horticulture
so that's just getting
started the recruitment of students like
that
may be a problem i've been asking around
people that are experienced in this area
and said
[Music]
it might be hard to find students that
want african-american students that want
to do horticulture what's horticulture
it doesn't pay anything
it's not very glamorous
so we may have a problem finding those
particular students that would be suited
for
this program
but we'll see
then lastly
okay
canadian
come here
really didn't have any money
and now you're doing all this
where does it come from well
it's mostly investment
uh i'm not an uh
investor
i know nothing about stock market but my
late wife betty played in the stock
market initially
and then uh she
got involved with metlife who said no
don't do it this way do it that way and
so on and so forth so she was the
primary influence
uh victor dillard who
many of you know
uh
was
our financial advisor and has been and
still is
and he's been
really key
to that
to that effort as well
so there you have it
okay while we're transitioning to listen
to hear from kawanga um
maybe i'll just mention that the
deadline for the new caja program is 10
days away so there's still time to apply
and all the information is on the
website
hello thank you so much for this
opportunity my name is kalenga banda i
am the outgoing kaha recipient and i'm
doing uh
research in sweet potato storage with
chris watkins
before i go into the slides to share a
bit of what my research has been about
i will just want to talk about my
background with kaha
how my experience has been so
i was
just coming out of my masters program at
stellenbosch university and i joined the
university of zambia and i was looking
for opportunities to get into grad
school and i had my eye on
two universities at uc davis and cornell
so as i was searching um
around for opportunities in cornell i
came across kaha and and for me that was
it i just felt that this was for me and
and
and i went for it
so
um
this uh program suited me especially
because having come out of a master's
program i worked on pomegranate research
and
and and there was no pomegranate in
zambia so i was feeling kind of
disconnected
how am i going to contribute to my
country and so i wanted to do research
that was uh going to be
be able to solve problems in my country
and so kaha provided an opportunity for
me to do research that could be able to
benefit farmers in in zambia and i
picked on sweet potato because it's it's
our staple crop is maize and and
everyone is doing research on maize corn
and and so i wanted to do something
different and i i and i knew that there
was a problem with storage of of um of
root crops and root crops was uh is is
an important staple especially when
there's a crop failure in maize people
usually will move on to to root crops so
then i
ventured into into this into this
research
but
life happened and when i came in when
when i came into cornell
uh we were not able to fully um
do as do what we planned covet came in
and a few other personal challenges came
in so most of my research was done here
in cornell and and we looked at some of
the areas that
u.s farmers um
to address some of the challenges that
u.s sweet potato farmers had but we also
had
one study that we did in zambia so i'll
share that at the very end and
also share how i plan to build on from
that particular study
so
so we worked on two problems we talked
we worked on sprouting in sweet potato
and also chilling injury and so
we
following on from the success uh
successful application of ethylene in
sweet potato storage in potato storage
we
ventured into research that would look
at the effects of both ethylene and one
mcp on sweet potato sprouting looking at
rates of sprouting but also looking at
sugar changes in in sweet potato and and
so we compared different cultivars and
and we found variable effects across
different cultivars
and then
we also looked at chilling damage
firstly looking at
how
cultivars vary in their sensitivity to
chilling damage and the purpose of that
work was be able to
get some cultivars that would be useful
uh for application of some interventions
to reduce chilling damage and sweet
potato and we picked on is it the red
one
we picked on on bella view
we picked on bellaview uh to uh um then
go on and do another study where we
looked at
the effects of curing to be able to
reduce chilling damage and i think from
the visual you can
you can see that this is a control
samples over 40 days and these were
keyword samples and and you can see by
day 40 that curing really reduced
chilling damage and not only that it did
reduce um
uh
uh hydrogen peroxide and also lipid
peroxidation so we found it as a very
useful uh
pre-harvest treatment to use to reduce
chilling damage
and then
this is the part uh this slide is about
some of the work that i did in zambia so
this was done in 2018 and this was a
study that was done to
assess some of the challenges that sweet
potato farmers have and this is me and
the team up there that went up to
northwestern and central zambia and we
did
a survey where we interviewed
farmers looking at some of their storage
practices some of the cultural practices
and some of the losses and and and
causes of losses that were associated
with those practices and then uh some of
the key things that came out were things
like pest damage but also uh the
techniques that they use for storage uh
uh we're predisposing the the roots to
to storage so many things came out of
this study and um uh i will be going
back to the university of zambia at the
end of early next year and i'm hoping to
build on from some of these findings to
be able to contribute to sweet potato
research and and many other
horticultural crops in
sub-saharan africa
so really cornell
caja has been a great opportunity to
get excellent
education and also
to be able to link up with top
researchers in the field and and i hope
to be able to um
continue with those collaborations and
and contribute to research in africa and
i my main goal is to be able to
contribute to research on a more
regional level so i have my eyes set on
regional organizations in in africa and
across
thank you
so sarah mentioned um
i was the advisor of the first kaha
student
charles mason
um
he's
from kenya originally from the village
of
obama where until recently uh the
president's grandmother
and his project was focused on green
beans
so there was some benefit to this
because the bean green bean community is
also linked to the dry bean community
and the bean community in general are a
pretty international community
so we were able to link with people like
tallow at usda beltsville tim porch in
puerto rico who also has a program in
angola
and we set up a project uh focusing on
green beans for
heat tolerance and rust tolerance they
they're a crop that are grown
in the higher regions of kenya uh lake
victoria is about 1100 meters
uh green beans do well when you get up
to the 12 1500 meter type of levels
where it's more
temperate
um and it is mostly an export crop
there
but only about 15 percent of the prop
gets exported so the 85 percent the
remains has actually kicked off quite a
nutritional domestic supply of that
problem
so
we worked together from 2006 to 2010.
but what was interesting is you know we
we traveled a lot around eastern africa
together on three or four visits
so we started looking at a lot of other
horticultural crops and i work with
brassica vegetables
and
probably this image right here
is the visit we made back in 2008 where
we started looking at a lot of the leafy
brassicas in africa
so google wiki is to push the weak it's
african cow
and interestingly this was the point i
think that about 13 or 14 years of work
on leafy brassicas has originated from
which now tells him to both the african
market and the kenyan market
so
super wiki is very important
it's one of the few nutritious crops
uh it's very common next to golly and
say beans there's a male
people go buy it at the
um
the local markets either as the direct
leaves or pre-chopped up ready to cook
and then it's sold really all it's grown
all the way around like victoria and
salt
so trade in markets where it goes to
these local markets oftentimes
so
this is a crop we decided to collaborate
with
when he went back because when he went
back he worked at i sippy for a little
bit at a point
he also went through a little bit on the
uganda sweet potato project
um but he had
got together with a friend of his danny
ambok
and dan had previously worked for usaid
so they got together to set up their own
company their own seed company in
western kenya
realizing that there were huge gaps in
the market especially for horticultural
crops
so they've set up uh advantage seat
limited um i was the first signatory in
their
book for the company
that they i like to have
so
with charles and dan setting up this
company this really helped to progress a
lot of these efforts
uh we also got funding from the atkinson
center back in 2011 for diversification
of leafy greens in eastern africa which
very much helped
and we've started to look at the
different types of leafy brassicas that
people might
like more or that might be better in the
different environments
and recently this also played into um a
phd student who graduated last year uh
hannah sweygarden
her focus was on kale mostly for the
american market
and she was very interested in uh
engaging consumers bringing consumers
into the breeding process getting
feedback from them from consumers to
inform decisions
so
we focused on both the kale types and
the sort of cooked collard types which
are more similar to the east african
african girls
to do consumer panels
but as part of this we linked
with charles
because you know it was an opportunity
to give hannah some international
experience it was an opportunity to
advance some of these efforts
and really get a different perspective
you know how do
consumers in east africa respond to
different types of kale compared to
consumers in
the us plus i think it's a
pretty valuable experience hannah got to
go out to eastern africa three times
during her phd
so i think just for any student that can
be um an incredible experience
um and the work that we set up with
charles was on two seasonal plantings
during the wet season
this is
charles's
location in rhodey western kenya
um
but hannah was able to go out a few
times the last time for about two or
three weeks staying in home at bay
and then working with charles to get
these sort of evaluations of what people
liked in the
different brassicas and sort of do this
contrast
so in the meantime this whole leafy
brassica for african kale
sort of
hit head-on with the kale
uh explosion in the u.s
it also linked with uh work that we were
doing on natural color in brassicas
so it's actually gone in two directions
now one of the directions is to develop
the leafy greens for the american market
the different colors and shapes this is
something we're doing in the toscano
type we're moving it to green and golden
with the purple thing
but also thinking about what might work
going back in the other direction for
african markets to try and promote
a
nutritional is high in nutrition but
is also very popular amongst consumers
there
so what we've been working towards now
is this toscano collard
because the supreme wicking is very
similar to the regular collar this flat
leaf
and it degrades very very quickly
what you have with this toscano collet
is
early nutritional work that we've done
has found that the kales that are high
in fiber are very high in correct mods
so this is very important from a
nutritional angle compared to the
flat leaf
but what you also get from
this toscano savoy leaf type is
something with
a much longer shelf life when you pick
it and take it to market
so you can take it perhaps a greater
distance
it's also a product that when you cook
it you have a much more product when it
cooks down so you don't lose
so much
of the solids during the cooking process
so it's also of course in hybrids you
can see the two parents that are here on
anywhere near the vigor of the hybrid
the hybrid can be
five times easily the yield of an op or
an ingredient pairing
so we've been developing these hybrids
and now we're hopeful that we can put
something together to go back and look
at how
these or even op mixers do against some
of the current varieties being grown
and we have these not only in the sort
of the dark green or the blue green but
also the bright green and even the
golden
and what's interesting about these i
think is that the us kale market is all
about the
raw vegetable market
where the texture gives it the crunch
and the volume and the ability to hold
dress in
so these are actually products that work
for both the expanding us markets
and to try and improve the east african
leafy brassica markets
so um work continues
with charles
uh we've had a couple of zooms in the
last couple of weeks with kalenga to
talk about how we can bring these kaha
relationships together
and progressing on some of these
projects whether we can have a sort of a
new york kenya um zambia
type of project going forward which i
think
could be um
pretty intriguing and pretty meaningful
in what it could contribute so
hopefully we're able to use that and we
all have our our different strengths to
bring to that uh kalanga's going to be
at the university of zambia
charles is a little bit of a wheeler and
dealer and he's linked to the corporate
side in
western kenya and probably i'm the
counterpart wheeler and dealer on on
this side
but we all have different types of
positions but i think they all come
together and complement one another
and i think provide a platform to pivot
from and do something that could be
quite special and quite minimal
so this is
we did have a chance at one point we
were down in dar salaam and we were
going to nairobi we've got to stop over
in
zanzibar this is downtown zanzibar if
you ever get the chance to be in that
region i absolutely recommend it
but i will pass it on to
julian
hello good afternoon everyone
my name is jillian at curry and i am the
incoming or current
kaha fellowship holder
and just before i start i just want to
say thank you to our founder
professor chris i mean this
for someone from africa it might not be
so obvious to someone here but for an
african this is a huge opportunity
and
the collaboration between africa and
the us
and the research i think it's uh really
needed because if you look at the
african setting
and the food systems and horticulture
there's a lot that needs to be done so
thank you pros
okay so my research i'll be looking at
mitigating affects and contamination in
low resource
regions and i'll be looking at
sub-saharan
africa in in particular and uganda
specifically
okay so just a brief introduction uh
aflatoxin contamination is a big problem
especially in the developing countries
because the countries have so many
challenges that make
them prone to afrotoxins in their
produce so
basically after toxin is a secondary
metabolite that is produced by the
fungus as faginas
and it is
contaminated contaminates both food and
animal feed and it's still
available in the food even after cooking
or drying so it's mostly produced by two
uh
fungi's strains that is asparticular
flavors and parasitic fats but can also
be produced by um
other strains though these are the most
uh
strains that produce uh aflatoxin
so it's basically very highly toxic if
you look at comparing comparing it to
other mycotoxins like ocra toxins and
humanising
this aflatoxin is more prevalent and
it's generally more toxic
so climatic conditions further fungal
growth
so if you look at sub-saharan i mean
subtropical and tropical regions
these
high temperatures and drought
conditions
make the fungus to produce more afro
toxins so i find that in addition to the
problems that the continent i means
radiation is facing
together with the climate
they both
make aflatoxin contamination a big
problem in africa
so the big problem is that there's
significant amounts of toxins in produce
from sub-saharan africa
and contamination occurs throughout the
value chain right from the field free
harvest add harvest during storage
and um also post harvest
so you find that contamination can occur
anywhere along the food value chain
which is a bit challenging and then the
other thing is that um
though after talking available in so
many products so you can have the kind
of maize
soy
all these products so gum and all that
the most uh susceptible products are
maize
and groundnuts so this is very important
because if you look at african food
systems
most african dance
most african dents are plant-based and
then you find that people consume
maize mostly as a carbohydrate sauce and
then ground it as the
um protein source
and then these two are very susceptible
so you find people consume these
products very often
there's very little um food options so
people consume a lot of maize and
granades which are susceptible to
contamination and then you find that
people are taking in
these
aflatoxins
so additionally there is poor regulation
and monitoring
low resource regions not only in
sub-saharan africa but other areas such
as india this is a very big problem if
you look at if you compare to the
developing countries
what uh
monitoring is is done as
a regular um system
it's very lacking actually almost none
evident basically in uh in laurissa's
region so this is a very big problem
because they find that at international
limit international markets
aflatoxin contamination
exceeds international limits so in the
u.s the limit is 20 parts per billion
but the europe has a more strict uh
market and the international limit is 4
percent billion so you can imagine how
hard it is to it is for an african
farmer
to get into international markets
okay so the other thing is that we have
very poor practices right from
pre-harvest first service and also
during storage additionally we have
transportation and marketing systems
which are a bit you know poor and a bit
lacking so this all together contributes
to the problem
now after toxins basically uh impacts
health but exposure can be either acute
or chronic
now the acute is when you're exposed to
very high amounts of aflatoxins
and
this usually causes uh hepatic necrosis
or mortality so there's an incident in
2004
in kenya where more than 100 people
actually died from consuming very
consuming maize that was contaminated
with aflatoxin so we can see how serious
the problem is
but then the other thing is chronic
exposure this one you're exposed to low
amounts of uh after toxins but over a
longer period of time so this leads to
its stunting especially in children
suppresses immunity and also liver
cancer and in africa this is the biggest
problem because people consume these
foods that have contaminated aflatoxins
and over a longer period of time so
you'll find that the chronic
chronic exposure is a big problem at the
moment
so the other thing is economic losses
like i mentioned earlier
people um
farmers rather produce from these
regions have um they do not meet the
international standards so i find the
products do not uh they are rejected
when they reach international markets
now the other thing is when these
products are rejects produce are
rejected from the international markets
they find our way back into the local
markets now what happens is these con
after toxin contaminated produce are
further processed into things like
peanut butter
or
powder or
paste or whatever and then they are sold
to consumers now after toxins are teslas
the odorless you cannot see them so
people consume
concentrated basically concentration of
aflatoxin in uh in in products which is
a big problem
so my research question is how can you
effectively mitigate aflatoxin
contamination
in low resource regions and for this
research i'll be specifically looking at
uganda now this is important because one
you want to protect consumer health and
then you want to improve competence of
the of the crop itself
and then we also want to contribute you
know to the food and nutrition security
problem and this is very important
because food security is already a
problem in africa so if you're bringing
an astrotoxin problem worsening the you
know the situation so if you can if you
can control this problem then maybe we
can actually improve
and contribute to food security in the
region
okay so
what uh what i'm proposing what we're
proposing to do is to improve soil
health so studies have shown that um
the fungus aspergillus fungus tends to
produce more aflatoxins in stress
conditions
so when
when there is drought when the
temperatures are high and also when the
are
soil
of nutrients
the aflatoxin contamination is going to
be much higher so um and these are all
of course contributing factors in in the
african region so if we if we can
improve soil health want to use an
organic fertilizer
and bio control and for bio control here
where you want to use okay studies have
shown that the atoxygenic strains that
is the non
aflatoxin producing strains of
they outcompete
the toxin producing strains
and then you have a healthier plant
less after toxins
uh and then generally better health
now the other thing we want to
incorporate in our research is the idea
of circular economy
where we want to use
sanitation waste as a fertilizer
for example urine using it as a
fertilizer
and then we shall use the fertilizer
oops sorry
we use a fertilizer to make
for to make
food more for food production
and then use food and market waste
to
make um
to reuse the food and market waste to
make products such as fertilizer and
biochar and these can again be used to
make more food
and then you have uh
basically the i want to incorporate the
idea of reusing and recycling products
or waste
so that uh you have you know an
environmentally friendly uh system and
this is very important in africa because
we want
available affordable and sustainable
solutions to the african problem so if
we can incorporate that and have a
holistic approach
then maybe we can um
improve on the
antitoxin problem in africa
thank you so much
thank you so we have a few minutes to um
have a q a so i'm going to ask all the
speakers to just flip their chair around
so we can all
have a conversation here
and um
yeah go ahead and ask your
questions
i have a question for you you can just
repeat it uh my question is did you work
in africa before charles was
your student
or did it or was it the caja that really
got that whole effort started no i've
been to africa a couple of times one for
friends quite and
but that's definitely what kicked off
all this stuff
and if you could put that right up next
to your mask i think that yeah there we
go
so my question is for uh
julian the last speaker
and um one thought i have yes
is that
the aflatoxin could be
growing uh because the
let's say peanut or maize have not has
not been dried completely
so could you tell me what what is the
drying of
method that is recommended for peanuts
let's say
okay so uh he's asking
about the drying method for
peanuts yeah specifically peanuts let's
say or a ground nut for groundnuts okay
all right so
uh for drying in africa basically the
most drying method that we use is uh sun
drying
that is the biggest method as long as
the water quantity goes
down to about seven percent then that is
enough
so if because uh it depends also on the
production i think so if you're having
large scale production then it doesn't
going through the drain the different
drying this had been compared to
um
a small holder cover but uh
but yeah it's mostly the sand drying
that is used yeah that sounds reasonable
so it's it's uh after harvest yes and
then sun dried and it's pretty effective
uh yeah it is fairly effective the only
the biggest problem is the
consistency
consistency so
it's weather very weather dependent and
so people have to it's very labor
intensive also people have to kind of
check them out then when it rains or
something put them back in and all that
so it's it's not very stable and
consistent and then that's why you have
the problem of moles molding because
water content sometimes you know
increases even as the drying oils
incompletely i mean it's not dried
completely so that becomes a bit
challenging but if done right it's very
effective yeah yeah
good
so
here in the back yeah i was also
wondering julian about um kind of the
mitigation techniques that you're going
to use on athletic toxins and would any
of those be like um
maybe a chemical treatment or maybe like
a uv treatment or something like that
that can disrupt the dna
they can have fun
okay so um for the techniques we
initially we think of going like post
harvest routes where we use all these
measures like uv and all that
but we we've decided to re-look at it
and focus mostly on the soil and the
plant because
after toxins are mostly produced more
after toxins that are produced where the
plant is stretched and when the soil is
poor so if we can
solve the problem at that level then we
can reduce on the post-harvest
situation
so what we want to do is look at the
soil health improve the soil health
because the healthcare plant is able to
hide the toxin fungus
and then also look at bio control
instead of the uv and all those measures
we look at bio control we are using the
atomogenic strength to outcompete the
atoms of toxin producing exchange of the
fungus so and this actually shows that
it's very stable but that once the
bio control is used
i mean during planting
you find that
during storage
waterfall service and also throughout
the contamination is way way way less
compared to if you look at the problem
at the from the post harvest uh
angle some more preventative measure
than anything else of course
it's a bit challenging to kind of um
especially like in your research region
it can get a bit challenging to look at
just for service because of resources
and you know time and availability
so i have a question for chris uh what
is your vision for kaha in the next
10 years 15 years
i hope it will keep
it will continue
with more students from africa
and now if we can find the students from
the african-american sector either in
canada or here
that that
number of students will also increase
and
if
we're going to have the kind of
collaborations that rick was talking
about
wouldn't that be marvelous
it could even be
a
program that expands
uh
post-graduation
amongst the people that
yeah i think that's the ideal for some
sort of network among some of the
different countries and institutions
develop the supermarkets and we go into
the apples from new zealand and the
oranges from south africa and the
tomatoes from israel all props to the
grown in that region
whilst the united
coffee for states times the value
the opportunity um
for really sustainable small bombing
life and higher value of crops then even
in the u.s
just
all right well thank you all for coming
today um again
the new haha program deadline is
december 1st so if you
can share that news of that program with
your networks that we most appreciated
so you get a robust poll of candidates
um thank you to each of our speakers
this has been a really inspiring hour to
hear about how
one uh person's vision can affect so
many lives across the continent and to
see these synergies across the network
um so thank you all so much please join
me in giving our panel a big round of
applause
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu